last week we got a major report from
mark german that apple was going to be
releasing at least one new mac at their
upcoming march 8th event and i already
told you guys that i'm 100 sure that
it's gonna be the new redesigned
high-end mac mini but just this morning
out of nowhere apple themselves have
actually confirmed that not one but
three brand new macs are coming at the
upcoming event which is mind-blowing
because we're already expecting a new
iphone sc and an ipad air and to make
things even more confusing one of them
is apparently gonna be a macbook yes a
macbook which we weren't expecting until
fall later this year so what i'm gonna
do in this video is give you guys a few
different scenarios for which max apple
could reveal at this upcoming event
based on all of the leaks and rumors so
before i get into the first scenario let
me show you guys how apple confirmed
these three new macs earlier this
morning apple registered three brand new
mac model numbers with the eurasian
economic commission and if you have no
idea why apple would do such a thing let
me explain due to government regulations
certain european countries require
companies to register any product that
features data encryption before it can
actually be sold in that country and if
you know anything about apple devices
almost all of them feature data
encryption so for the past few years
apple has registered basically every
major encrypted device with the eec at
least a couple of weeks before an event
would take place and it's no different
this time around with these three mac
models and mark german even chimed in
and quote tweeted about the new filings
by apple saying that he's expecting
multiple macs at the march event so he
agrees now in the past sometimes apple
would file extra numbers that wouldn't
end up getting released until later but
in my opinion i think all three of these
macs are getting released at the march 8
event next month and let me explain why
in october of 2020 apple filed for eight
new mac model numbers which all ended up
being apple's m1 max but the most
interesting point is that the three m1
max that launched in november of 2020
started with
a23 while the two imacs that were
delayed until the spring of 2021 started
with a24 almost like apple knew that
they would be released in the future and
if you look at the three brand new model
numbers that we just got they all start
with a26
so that's my reasoning for all of them
coming at this event and the last
extremely important point that i want to
mention is that one of the numbers quite
literally says
computer which means portable personal
computer which has always turned out to
be a macbook in the past and even though
this goes against all common sense in
terms of apple's mac lineup and what i
personally thought was gonna happen i
think it's pretty clear that apple is
releasing a new macbook at their event
next month and if that sounds too crazy
to believe i honestly think that there's
no other option because the next event
we're all expecting is wwdc in june and
i don't think there's any way apple
would release a macbook at that event
because we've had rumors of other
products being released in june like for
example mark german believes there's a
chance that apple will reveal the apple
silicon mac pro at wwdc and then on top
of that we had rumors of apple showing
off their vr headset and now ross young
is doubling down once again on apple
revealing the imac pro in june as well
so i honestly don't think there's any
room for a macbook announcement in june
and with that said the next probable
event for a macbook reveal would be in
october which is eight months from today
so there's absolutely no way that they
would make this filing this early so
that likely means that this new macbook
is getting released next month and the
craziest thing of all is that this isn't
the first time that we're hearing about
this because just last week digitimes
reported that apple's entry-level m2
macbook pro would launch in early march
and at the time this made absolutely
zero sense and everybody basically
laughed off the rumor because digitimes
isn't particularly reliable but then
mark german reported that apple would
hold a march 8th event and release at
least one new mac which pretty much
backs up the digitimes report and then
of course just this morning we got that
new eec filing pointing to a macbook
releasing next month so what if digit
times actually received some early
insider information and what if it
actually comes true with a new m2
macbook pro launching next month well in
my opinion if we are truly getting a new
macbook next month i think it will
definitely be a new entry level macbook
pro for a couple of different reasons
first of all the redesigned macbook air
isn't supposed to go into mass
production until the third quarter of
this year according to mingxikuo which
is usually really reliable second of all
i don't think that apple would want to
show off another product redesign at the
same event since i fully believe that
they'll be also showing off the new mac
mini design and if you think about it
apple has already shown off the 14 inch
macbook pro redesign last year so if
this new macbook pro does come it would
be using the same 14-inch redesign but
obviously with different specs and
features and then finally i actually
think it makes sense for apple to
release the m2 chip within the macbook
pro first to avoid the really crappy
situation that happened with the
original m1 macbooks and if you don't
remember the m1 macbook air was 300
cheaper than the macbook pro while not
really being much slower so we basically
told everyone to avoid the m1 macbook
pro because it simply wasn't worth the
extra cash so if apple releases the m2
macbook pro first by itself they can
guarantee that no one is going to be
choosing the air over the pro since the
air is not going to be available until
later this year and all of that makes
sense to me but with all that said we've
established that we're getting a
high-end m1 pro and m1 max mac mini
revealed at the event as well as an
entry-level macbook pro but that still
leaves one mystery eec filing for a
brand new mac so let me go through all
the possible scenarios for what it could
end up being for the first scenario
there's a chance that two of those eec
filing numbers are actually both for the
same new mac mini model because last
year we got two separate numbers for the
24 inch imac one for the two port model
and one for the four port so what if
there's one filing for the m1 pro chip
and one filing for the m1 max model or
what if there's one for the 10 gigabit
ethernet option and one for the base
model well i ended up doing some
research by looking at previous model
numbers and i found out that the m1 mac
mini only has one eec model number
regardless of whether it got 10 gigabit
ethernet or not and then i also looked
back at the m1 pro and m1 max macbooks
and found that there was literally just
one model number for the 14-inch and one
for the 16-inch regardless of the chip
options so what that tells us is that
the third eec number that was filed this
morning has to be a different mac no
matter what so for this second scenario
what if the third mac is actually going
to be a new apple silicon 27-inch mac
model that will also come with just the
m1 pro and max chips because all the
leaks and rumors talking about a june
launch are specifically talking about
the higher end imac pro so what if apple
does in fact release a regular high-end
27-inch imac at next month's event which
is going to feature the same exact
27-inch 5k 60hz imac panel without any
sort of mini led or promotion technology
for a base price of around two thousand
dollars and since there would be no
display changes it could have flown
under ross young's radar since he's
mostly tracking the new mini led display
for the imac pro and there would really
be no way for him to know if a new
regular 27 inch 5k imac is coming if the
display didn't change but then again it
would require apple to show off two
brand new redesigns within the same
event which kind of makes it unlikely on
top of the fact that all the credible
leakers out there haven't said a word
about there being two 27-inch imac
models so this is a bit of a stretch but
i'm still holding onto hold and now for
the third and final scenario if apple is
truly revealing the m2 macbook pro next
month then why not release a second mac
with the m2 chip at the same time and no
i don't mean the macbook air i mean the
base level m2 mac mini because if
they're already taking time out of the
event to show off the redesigned
high-end mac mini why not at the same
time release the lower end m2 version
which would use the same chassis and
then they would instantly replace both
the m1 and the intel mac mini models and
then later in the year at the october
event they could release both the m2
macbook air and the m2 24 inch imac to
complete the m2 lineup which could
totally make sense but then again a lot
of people might make the mistake of
thinking the m2 mac mini was faster than
the m1 pro and max which could be a bit
confusing so with that said i think the
most likely scenario is the second one
with apple releasing an m1 pro and m1
max 27 inch imac now if you totally
disagree with me then let me know down
in the comment section below but if you
enjoyed this video go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]